hey you guys movie retrospective time
doing another stephen king adaptation
would you say this is one of the better
ones or better one of the worst ones one
of the worst one of the better ones i
think this is actually one of the better
ones it's one that doesn't really get
talked about all that much i feel like
it's one that's sort of cause like i
don't know i feel like when we were
talking about graveyard shift that
so many adaptations have been made of
stephen king's stuff that it's like easy
for someone to like fall through the
cracks especially if they're not like
super spectacular but i think this is a
pretty solid one actually well it's a
giant jet movie yeah and i back when
that mess onto it well you know
it's funny because this came out this is
secret window by the way uh which is
based on the novella called secret
window secret garden
um that came out when did that come out
1990 i think it was in one of his uh you
know he did um those books uh that had
like four novellas in them this one was
called four past midnight i think it was
the same the same book that had the
langoliers and a couple other stories in
it that i don't think have been adapted
but
yeah so this is based on uh that novella
that came out in 1990
and it's weird because i kind of feel
like secret window
it's the movie and the story
i almost kind of feel like
it's very very similar to the dark half
yeah you know what i'm saying like even
the movie is kind of like yeah and it's
you know i know a lot of stephen king's
stuff is about a writer um but
the way that this story
plays out reminds me very much of the
dark half like it's a really similar
what year this come on this uh the movie
came out in 2004. okay yeah
so this was actually directed by uh
david kepp
who also did one of my favorite horror
movies of all time star of echoes
um probably better known as a
screenwriter i feel like he did like
some of the jurassic park movies and
[ __ ] like that so he's like you know
done screenwriting on a lot of [ __ ]
movies and directed some some of them
not so good but he did do stir of echoes
which is a great movie if you haven't
seen it i recommend it all the time but
uh yeah so
this movie came out
right when
it was just maybe like a year after the
first pirates of the caribbean movie so
you know johnny depp was really like
having a big moment
so i kind of feel like they pushed the
fact of him being in this movie even
more than
it being a stephen king adaptation i
don't even think they put like from the
story by stephen king like on the poster
or anything if i'm remembering there
might have been a detriment at that in
2004
maybe yeah because i kind of feel like
most of his stuff like when that would
have been a big selling point would have
been like in the 80s or maybe the 90s
but by the time the 2000s had rolled
around i think people didn't really care
anymore yeah he was kind of uh the
stephen king name
the the steamin the stephen king name
kind of waxed and waned yeah over the
years in terms of quality you know what
i mean so maybe just the timing wasn't
right to sell this as a stephen king
adaptation
yeah because they really think the time
is back actually
well yeah like i said they've done a
[ __ ] ton of stephen king adaptations
lately like netflix has done a bunch of
them and it's like you got big [ __ ]
directors doing it you know they did dr
sleep they did all kind of [ __ ] like
that which that extended version of
[ __ ] doctor sleep not the theatrical
cup the extended cut is good yeah much
better than the theatrical kind of now i
kind of feel like okay so to talk about
this movie we're gonna have to spoil it
um and i'm probably also gonna have to
spoil the story which i have read but i
read it a long time ago um the movie and
the story even though the you know the
plot is the same
the movie actually changes the ending in
a way that
i kind of prefer
uh honestly the movie has a darker
ending than the story does
and
even though the plot's kind of the same
like the mechanism of it is a little bit
different which like i said kind of
shades into why it reminds me so much of
the dark half but i'll get into that in
a bit
so what we got uh johnny depp is playing
a writer uh you know like many of
stephen king's protagonists are
and his name is mort rainey or morton
rainey
he's like a crime writer i guess like
mosquitoes writes noir type stuff from
mysteries
so
at the beginning of the movie you have
this scene where
uh he's finding his wife banging some
other dude like in a motel someplace and
he gets real upset about it
and uh then they cut to six months later
and apparently what's been happening is
that
johnny depp or let's let's just call him
this is let's call him johnny
[Laughter]
his character has a name but we're just
going to call him johnny depp because
he's [ __ ] johnny that's kind of like
tom cruise tom cruise always plays
himself johnny depp plays himself yeah
and it's pretty much just kind of like
the you know the john johnny deppiness
or the tom cruisiness is just like so
overwhelming that like you can't even
usually remember the names of their
characters yeah it doesn't matter yeah
so so yeah so johnny depp say cut to six
months later um apparently the the cheat
and wife has gotten to keep the nice
house
which i guess is in upstate new york or
somewhere like that i think is where
it's at the story's set in vain
obviously but i think the movie's
upstate new york uh while johnny depp
has gone off to their vacation cabin i
guess it's sort of like this isolated
sort of place and uh it doesn't seem
like he's doing too well laying around
in the same ratty bathrobe sleeping on
the couch all day
has written maybe one paragraph of
something that he thinks sucks and then
he deletes it so he's just there kind of
like talking to himself talking the dog
or whatever yeah it's 2004 when you're
eating doritos
2004 but he's living in 1994 actually
have you noticed that yeah it's
basically living like it's 1994. yeah
yeah
yeah it's just everybody's just kind of
laying around and honestly i think they
do a scene like later where it shows
that his wife like when the back when
they were first married when they were
still married uh the wife had that robe
on so that's actually his wife's robe
that he's wearing but it's all like torn
up and stuff so it's like who knows how
long he's been because it looks like he
doesn't change his clothes or comb his
hair or anything like that he looks like
he's kind of like you know losing his
marbles a little bit
so he's up there he's got all these kind
of problems
and then a really big problem arrives in
the form of
john turturro playing a character named
john shooter
who comes in with his real thick
mississippi accent yeah his [ __ ]
stephen king and his yankee [ __ ]
racially stereotype and southerners
again [ __ ] yeah although guys were
always got the southern accent although
um in in the story's defense and this is
like i said a spoiler alert john shooter
is not a real person right he is a
projection yeah well so was the so was
the bad guy from the [ __ ] dark half
and he was from jones county mississippi
yeah i remember that i forgot i hadn't
seen the dark half in a long time i
remember because okay now wasn't it
original mississippi badass was it yeah
uh timothy hutton in the dark half
because timothy hutton is in this movie
too yeah playing the dude that uh johnny
depp's wife was was cheating on him with
i don't know so yeah so he's not in it a
lot but he's in this one as well i'm
pretty sure he was also in the dark
house yes if you grow up in maine
anybody from mississippi is a badass
[Laughter]
i don't know i tend to agree if you were
growing up in maine anybody from
mississippi is a badass from your point
of view but yeah so so this john shooter
fella shows up
on his doorstep and basically says you
stole my story uh you plagiarized like i
wrote this story that was called now his
story was called sewing season not
sewing like sewing but sewing like farm
kind of [ __ ] um
and he's like and this is like pretty
much the same as mine now obviously
johnny depp is not uh you know he's he's
like you're crazy get the [ __ ] off you
know what i mean and it seems like they
kind of imply later on too that
he um had had like similar run-ins
before where they get like you know the
nutty fans and [ __ ] like that which is
actually based on real life because i
think stephen king has had he had one
woman
that
for like a very long period of time kept
saying that he stole all of her
like all of her stories you know what i
mean like she was just she was just some
nutcase but um so he's kind of like
writing from experience
uh and i think he had i don't know if it
was the same person but it's one of them
like broke into their house or did
something like that they're not their
main house but their vacation house so
that's kind of where he got the idea
from this that's at least that's what i
heard
so uh so he's just like yeah whatever
you're just some nutcase and just like
piss off but then he kind of gets
curious about it
and he looks up um that he had written
this story many years before called
secret window
and he goes and finds it and he's like
reading that reading it it's like been
um you know anthologized in one of his
later books and it is almost exactly the
same like a little a little bit of it is
different and the ending is different
and he's just like huh maybe is there
any way that i could have done that
because it does kind of come out later
it's implied that he had had an
accusation of plagiarism before
and it had been settled out of court so
they leave it ambiguous as to whether he
had actually stolen somebody else's
story before or not you know what i mean
so
so this whole thing happens now
so he starts to think well maybe there's
some way that i could have read it or
something like that but so this dude
keeps like hanging around
and then it comes to light that john
shooter
says that he wrote this story in 1997.
but then johnny depp is like well [ __ ]
you because i wrote this story in 1994
and it was published in a in a mystery
magazine and i have proof of it like
it's at my old house
so jon shooter is basically like okay
well i'll give you three days to come up
with the proof and if you don't have
that we're gonna like you know tangle
and one of us is gonna end up dead he's
like very threatening
so as it goes on like johnny depp is
gonna go back to his old marital home
where his wife still lives um and you
know the the new boyfriend comes by
there what was his name ted i think his
name was ted
he comes by there all the time so he's
gonna go pick the magazine up but then
he goes and then she's there and he just
like chickens out or whatever and then
it ends up later on that john shooter
not only kills johnny depp's dog chico
uh putting a [ __ ] uh what do you call
it through the screwdriver through its
head or whatever
um but then
after he says that he's gonna go get the
magazine uh john shooter apparently
burns down
the house
uh and apparently the magazine that goes
with it i don't know like why
one thing about this and like i said in
in the story's defense uh you know john
shooter is not a real person uh you know
spoiler alert like i said so johnny depp
is just kind of like doing all this
stuff himself but you know he's
dissociated
and i thought it was funny and i think i
thought it was funny when i read the
story too that it's like it was such a
big pain in the ass to get their hands
on this magazine i'm like do you not
have a library i'm like i'm sure the
library would have
a copy of it or whatever but it's like
yeah so the house burns down that has
this uh you know that has the story in
it
at which point johnny depp is like
freaking out he's like oh my god like
this dude is like really serious and
he's really a threat and so he goes and
hires
um
a guy who i guess is like a private
detective i think yeah uh he who's
played by um charles s dutton which who
i love that guy he's in like a bunch of
stuff he's pretty much the same
character that was out of thinner
yeah yeah yeah that same thing happened
to that guy who got cursed higher a damn
private investigator that well actually
no i think he was a mafioso that was
kind of like a private investor wouldn't
he a mafia hit man
yeah he might have been i haven't seen
thinner in a long time either but yeah i
think he was a hit yeah i think he was a
hit man but he had a lot of the skills
for a private detective and a cop and
and a soldier all kind of com but the
the characters kind of reminded me the
same had the same function in the story
yeah because you always kind of want
yeah and in this one he was kind of i
guess he was a private detective and i
guess that he had hired him before so i
guess he was also like a friend of his
um because they said oh is this like
last time or whatever and he's also like
some muscle so i'm guessing this guy's
maybe if you need somebody to like you
know if you wanna if you want him to go
bump somebody off it looked like he
would probably do that too
but you know what i mean so he's
basically like okay well i'm gonna come
up and
you know check out your cabin and like
make sure the dude's not there
and you know threaten him and get him to
like back off you and [ __ ] like that and
maybe you know if we have to do
something else we have to do something
else
but
despite that it's still getting really
like you know it just keeps escalating
and uh charles s dutton's character i
can't remember the character's name was
but i just remember the actor's name but
he basically other than being the muscle
he also says oh well i called your
literary agent and i'm going to get them
to you know like fedex you or you know
send you like really quickly the another
copy of the magazine so you can give it
to that dude and maybe he'll piss off
and leave you alone
so that so that whole thing is gonna
happen so that's coming in the mail
and um
so then it turns out
that nobody else around town has seen
this john shooter person
um you know johnny depp goes to the cops
and like tries to describe him but the
cops don't really seem to give that much
of a [ __ ] like they're not even like
really listening to him
and so he's trying to think of like
anybody else who would have seen this
person um because it just seems like the
dude just kind of pops up like on his
property like just out of nowhere
and so he he remembers back to this one
day he's like when i was kind of on the
side of the road like talking to this
guy and this other dude in town like a
farmer whoever like drove by and saw
both of us so it's like let's bring that
guy in and he can help you like you know
because he's seen him and he can
describe him and [ __ ] like that so you
can start looking for him but then it
turns out what so johnny depp and like
bill s dutton you know his his muscle
are going to meet with this dude that
supposedly saw the two of them and kind
of get their [ __ ] together but then
johnny depp turns up at the meeting
place and nobody's there
uh you know they never turned up
so then it turns out that john shooter
apparently has killed both of these
people and has kind of like
you know like used johnny depp's stuff
like his little hatchet and like his
screwdriver or whatever so it looks like
johnny depp did it and he's like look
i'm gonna like tell the cops because i
can just disappear you better get rid of
these bodies and all this other kind of
[ __ ] so that's what uh johnny depp ends
up having to like put the like push the
car into the [ __ ]
ravine or whatever like the big [ __ ]
what are those things called like with
the cliff with the water at the bottom
you know what i'm going to put the water
i can't take it i know that i know
there's a word for that it's not a
ravine it's something but it's something
down in the [ __ ] ditch we just called
the ditch it wasn't no it was way way
way beyond a ditch it was just like a
big
cliff with like a lake at the bottom you
know what i'm saying what's it for
that's where he like pushed the truck
into with the bodies in it i don't know
what to tell you
yeah i don't know yeah it's like a
quarry but it has water at the bottom
that's all i'm saying i just like no
well i just thought
well that's the word that i thought of
but i'm like that's not a that's not
exactly what that tastes more like a
spring that's what i mean that's not
exactly like that so anyway he just like
pushes off a cliff and into like the
water
but unfortunately while he's trying to
like push it over like his watch gets
caught like on the thing so it's like if
they ever find it you know he'll it'll
be identify him or whatever so
now that that whole [ __ ] [ __ ] has
happened
then it's like his ex-wife whose name is
amy uh is starting to worry about him
because think he's like kind of losing
his marbles or whatever and then she's
worried that they're how you know their
house burned down and like there's this
guy that's out after you and all this
other kind of crap
so
it turns out too that i think uh johnny
depp for a time thinks that ted his
wife's new boyfriend
uh was the one that hired john
shooter just to like come up there and
[ __ ] with him because another thing is
that johnny depp is supposed to be like
signing the divorce papers but he's like
been putting it off
so there's that whole issue too so he
actually kind of gets in a little bit of
a tussle with ted because he thinks that
ted
is behind everything
um so basically what happens from there
is that uh his wife starts freaking out
it's like okay i'm gonna come up there
and see what the [ __ ] is going on
but before she right before she gets
there the big reveal of the movie is
that like i said um
john shooter actually never existed he's
not a real person uh he's basically just
a symptom of johnny depp's like
dissociative
identity disorder
and so johnny depp
has been the one doing all this stuff he
was the one that killed the dog he was
the one that killed uh his bodyguard
dude he was the one that killed the guy
the the witness guy he was the one that
um burned the house down
and he did all this stuff yeah well i
said that like a bunch of times i said i
was gonna spoil it like i said
um so basically so when his wife gets
there
he's kind of clipped over into john
shooter mode and decides he's going to
kill her because that's kind of like
that's why he got had the name shooter
because it sounds like shoot her um so
that's kind of what he wanted to do and
like it was sublimated so he was kind of
like a split personality sort of thing
like this whole time now in the original
short story
i'm pretty sure
that
much like in the dark half or at least
what i'm remembering of the dark half
i thought that
in the story
um
mort
he had like
actually manifested this person as like
a real person he wasn't a real person
like he came out of his imagination
but he was actually a real dude that
could do things you know what i'm saying
he like manifested them whereas in the
movie it's made pretty clear
that johnny depp's character
um is just acting like that guy so that
guy doesn't actually exist that's just
who he sees when he's so he made up that
dude yeah that's what i'm saying so and
the reason that he made him from
mississippi was because he misperceived
that
his ex-wife's boyfriend was from
mississippi because there's a scene
where he just says what's that accent is
that mississippi and the guy said no i'm
from tennessee
um but he thought that he was from
mississippi and that's why he made the
bad guy like from mississippi that's
what i was saying pretty sure though
that in the original story at least what
i remember of it um had a happier ending
like i said in the story
john shooter was an actual person even
though he kind of like sprang from the
imagination of mort rainey uh in this
one he's not a real person it's actually
just johnny depp doing all of it but at
the end of the original short story
the wife and ted and [ __ ] like that do
come up there but i think they survive
uh spoiler alert again in the movie
johnny depp kills them both
like basically he he kills her well he
wounds her and then she was just gonna
go up to the cabin like by herself um
you know and tell ted she's like look i
just want him to go i want to go up
there see if he's okay get him to sign
the divorce papers and then i'm gonna
come back but ted thinks some things
matter so he like follows her without
her knowing uh she actually gets up
there
and johnny depp starts like [ __ ] her
up because he's got the hat on now like
the john shooter hat and uh so he starts
[ __ ] her up like stabs around the
ankle and you know starts dragging
around and everything and uh so she's
like he's gonna drag her outside and
she's wounded and then ted runs up and
uh johnny depp essentially like just
bashes in the face with a shovel and
then it looks like they don't actually
show it but it looks like he either like
beheads him with the shovel or just like
bludgeons him to death or whatever
and then uh also ends up killing the
wife
and then he buries them
in this garden that's like underneath
the whatever and it's kind of funny
because they go they jump ahead like a
little while
and i guess like now he's kind of like
gotten some his life together a little
bit like he got braces to fix his teeth
and he's combing his hair now and it
looks like he's washing his clothes and
he's cleaned his like cabin up because
it was a disaster and all this other
[ __ ] but now every time he goes into
town everybody looks at him all funny
because
um you know they obviously suspect
that
he's responsible for all these missing
people even though they haven't found
any of the bodies so basically the
sheriff is just like um we know you did
it we just can't prove it because we
don't have the bodies so it's like can
you like not come into town anymore
because you're making everybody really
uncomfortable and uh so basically that
but that's kind of how it ends but then
they show
uh you know the the garden like out the
little window or whatever and uh this
all this corn has grown and it's this
thing where johnny depp's like eating
the corn cob so he's basically saying
that he's like the bodies were under
there fertilizing the corn and then it's
like he's kind of getting rid of the
bodies that way um i think in the
original version of the movie at least
what i heard was that we get because at
the end it like pans down like to the to
the you know corn cobs or whatever and
then like it went to the dirt and i
think it showed the bodies like under
there but i think in the theatrical in
the theatrical version they don't show
that because i guess they thought it was
like johnny depp eating the corn yeah he
just like shows us go like like crunch
and that's like the end of it um because
so i thought that was kind of
interesting i was watching another
review of this movie
where they said they thought it was
interesting that
the uh the ending of the story within
the movie like the one that john shooter
says that you know that johnny depp
stole from him
um that was like a big bone of
contention because jon shooter was
saying that it's like you know you stole
my story and you [ __ ] the ending up
because my ending was much better and
that was kind of one of the things he
wanted him to do was change the ending
to his ending which he thought was
better and then like republish and put
his name come out with his name on it
and stuff like that but it's like i just
thought it was funny that that was like
such a big deal in the movie and then in
the actual movie it's very meta in the
actual movie
they actually did change
the ending of stephen king's original
story and they changed it for the movie
uh to where and they actually changed it
in the same way that the in-story story
was changed in the sense that
you know i i think in the original story
he didn't kill him and that or he didn't
kill his wife and then he wanted to
change it to he did kill his wife and
that's exactly the same thing that they
did in real life so like i said i
thought that was kind of funny and like
kind of meta so as i said this does
remind me very much of the dark half
like thematically it's very very similar
because isn't that it and i haven't read
the dark half in a long time or seen the
movie but that's essentially the same
thing right is he like a writer or
something like that but he like
manifests like another side of himself
but he doesn't really manifest manifests
a [ __ ] evil character from a series
of books that [ __ ]
his fans loved it yeah he didn't really
like that character that character was
kind of like
an anti version of him
from he was just as badass [ __ ] from
mississippi in a hot rod who
would just go around and [ __ ]
basically rape barmaids and [ __ ] beat
dudes up she was almost like act like
like a 80s action anti-hero type guy
i think he was a
he was just and he was just kind of a
[ __ ] wandering badass that's how i
remembered that character
and he was gonna
kill the character in in the series kill
the character off
he did kill the character off and then
they made it
they even had a a a ceremony like a fake
funeral for that character because he
didn't want to write any more of those
books
and that character comes out of another
dimension and [ __ ] tries to fight for
his life to [ __ ] get him to write the
books that's right
out of the two stories i'd rather watch
the dark half honestly yeah i mean this
is actually a pretty solid uh stephen
king adaptation yeah um i haven't seen
the dark half in a long time i remember
that one being a lot a little bit more
fun i think just because it was like a
little it was more fun more paranormal
stuff happened and
it wasn't as well shot it's it's not a
modern movie this is a lot more of a
modern type movie yeah cause dark half
that was 90s right i want to say and it
kind of had
i think it was 90s very early 90s maybe
it kind of had
the cheese factor that some of the
that some of the the the
stephen king movies had like this wasn't
a carry this definitely wasn't carrie it
definitely wasn't [ __ ] christine or
anything it was
closer to maximum overdrive but not that
bad you know what i mean that that's
what the dark calf was dark cap was
actually probably in terms of quality
probably closer to like thinner
yeah which i kind of remember that being
sort of fun too okay yeah
in some ways depending on what the story
is i think in some ways it's better to
go a little bit campy yeah or funny with
it just so it's like kind of fun yeah
this one had well i kind of like this
one though because this one has
humor in it but the humor is pretty
subdued
um and i actually kind of like honestly
i gotta say i think this is one of
johnny depp's best
performances
um just because i like the subtle humor
of the character and i like
um you know i like the whole thing where
you think that he's like a sympathetic
character this whole time like you know
a poor guy like his wife cheated on him
and now he's like he can't get his life
together and now this crazy person has
like come to his cabin and is like
threatening his life like over this
story or whatever um but then it turns
out that he's a lunatic you know what i
mean so i kind of like that sort of
switchy switcheroo aspect but i mean
some of the [ __ ] that he does in this
just like made me laugh out loud like
the [ __ ] where he's like sleeping on the
couch like all day and then like the
phone rings or somebody comes to the
door or something and he goes he's like
interrupted then he goes back to the
couch he's like now where was i that
just lays back that on the couch so it's
just like little like funny things like
that and he has like all these weird
little
um
little like little physical tics and
like weirdos like he does this weird
thing with his jaw
and like you know every time he washes
his hands he like makes this weird like
like he's
you know drying him off like that like
he can't dry him off so he's got like
all these little
subtle ticks at the beginning that kind
of i guess clue you in that he's not all
there uh but i think it's pretty he's
he's not like at his super depuist no
you know what i mean where he's real he
he's eccentric but it's not like over
the top
eccentric remember the remember the
movie where he played like uh the book
collector and they were looking for the
satanic book the ninth gate ninth gear
yeah we just talked about that not too
long ago it's almost kind of reminded me
a little bit of the ninth gate in some
weird way
in terms of quality level i like
watching the ninth gate yeah this is not
a it's a solid flick
it's not it's not a bad flick it's a
solid flick
but like i said
it's real close to the dark half i think
i'd rather see the dark calf
yeah we'll have to do that one one of
these days too because like i said i
remember i remember liking that one was
that the one that had like the the birds
like the psychopaths yeah yeah yeah it
came and tore them apart and you just
turned into paper yeah that's right
i remember that one being a little bit
more like because this one is pretty it
was a battle of will between two
different dimensions the guy just
refused to ride him and he just [ __ ]
was
falling apart yeah he had his kid and
was trying to threaten him to yeah
that's right and stuff
and i think the reason why the dark half
was good is because it was obviously a
paranormal story and it was paranormal
from [ __ ] the very beginning of the
story
uh the movie had a right tone for the
time
and the villain [ __ ] was right
he was just this
here the thing is he did not have a
[ __ ] accurate mississippi accent but
he did have a [ __ ]
kind of like a cross between a hot rod
and a luxury car some kind of rare
[ __ ] car from what i remember
i don't think they made very many it was
[ __ ] weird looking 70s car
and said highly toned son of a [ __ ] on
the back of it because he had it [ __ ]
tuned
and he just wore a [ __ ] black suit
and a [ __ ]
kind of dress like stevie ray vaughan he
had a black suit with [ __ ] cowboy
boots on the outside of his [ __ ] suit
pants remember that just [ __ ] yeah
[ __ ]
guns 40 carried a 45 and a knife and he
started to fall apart he's wearing black
leather gloves he was like an outlaw
yeah but you know i'm more of a 70s or
80s type outlaw
and he was a good character
this one i kind of feel like well the
john shooter character kind of comes
across more as
almost like a weird like an evil
preacher yeah type character like he
looks very dour or an evil super fan
kind of comes across that yeah slightly
nerdy like a uh yeah um
like a like like an evil obsessed super
fan kind of comes across that a nerd
somebody who would you know
you know obsess over details and [ __ ]
over books and [ __ ] that they didn't
write it's hard to say
you weren't sure if he was bullshitting
or if it was real
i thought he was bullshitting i thought
at first i just thought
he thought that that writer was stealing
his books right you know but then it
turned out that and it was kind of just
like because johnny depp was in a lot of
ways everything that he came up with
about that character
was either plucked from his own life or
from [ __ ] that he wasn't dealing with or
you know or the the fact that he made
the guy like think that he was
plagiarizing him was because he had been
accused of plagiarism before
and it had really like struck a chord in
him so that's why that's how that
manifests watching the movie didn't dawn
on me that the guy was a figment of his
imagination took a while
yeah i kind of feel like it's you know
it's
i kind of feel like the movie's old and
a lot of people have read the story and
a lot of people have seen the movie so
it's like i feel like most people know
what the twist is now i'm not sure
um because i'd already read the story so
i don't really know how obvious it is
that
that that's not the same that it's you
know that that's not a real person
um i don't know i watched a couple other
reviews of it and like some people that
hadn't read the story they said they
didn't see it coming but i don't know i
kind of feel like nowadays like maybe
you would see it coming i'm not really
sure because that's a pretty common i
feel like that's a pretty common twist
nowadays it's like oh the person was
fake all along especially because i
think the one shot that gives it away
is a little bit is the shot where
he's supposedly talking to john shooter
like on the side of the road and then
that guy what's that guy's name
greenleaf or whatever tom greenleaf
whatever that guy's name is um when he
goes by in the truck and it's almost
kind of like i don't want to say it's
like slow motion but they kind of make a
big deal of this other guy going by in
the truck and like seeing them
um and the fact that they made kind of
like a big deal about just a car going
by um kind of makes you think oh maybe
that dude's not really there because
that's gonna come into play later which
it does so i don't know so i don't know
how obvious it is but like like you said
the dark half is a much more like openly
paranormal story whereas this one is
more psychological because like i said
in the end
um you know that person doesn't exist
it's just a manifestation of his
craziness uh and he's been the one doing
it all along like he just goes and puts
the hat on and he becomes that other
person um and he but he just sees
himself as that other person yeah i mean
you know if you're a stephen king fan or
johnny depp fan you haven't seen this
you'd like it it's pretty good yeah like
i said i don't know i'm not sure how how
widespread or how widespread the
knowledge is that it's based on stephen
king's story it's not all obvious but
it's not yeah i mean it has all the
stephen king kind of troops there like a
writer that has writer's block and yeah
all this other kind of stuff so there's
very stephen king aspects in it but
i don't know maybe you wouldn't know if
you just watched it and you didn't know
you wouldn't know if it was based on
stephen king or not i'm not really sure
i i still we're gonna say i'd rather see
the dark half if you guys haven't seen
the dark half watch that first well like
i said we should basically we should do
one of those we should we should do a
respectively
we need to see we need to do the thinner
we need to do thinner and we need to do
fire starter i don't think we did fire
starter did we
i don't think we did
i thought we had done fire starter but
i'd have to go back and look i don't
think we did um but yeah we definitely
haven't done dark half and we definitely
haven't done thinner yeah although i
just watched thinner not too long ago
like maybe last year or something like
that i remember liking it yeah
like i said it's it's kind of like it's
good
yeah i mean you know that was definitely
worth yeah i was
every time i was like reading that i was
like man i wish some gypsy would give me
but a curse i made it like lose weight
that'd be awesome yeah but it didn't
stop well i know that
well that's the downside yes downside of
that all right so that'll do it for this
movie retrospective and we will see you
guys on the next one bye